i want that show back on the air well
hey fred are you uh gonna say something
i see your camera is up i'm confused
no sorry about that i hit a button that
shouldn't have been hit
my apologies well as long as you're here
how you doing man i'm doing great what's
happening ronnie needs to make a
decision soon
i don't know i'm just so undecided about
everything what do you mean
like i don't even give a [ __ ] if i vote
anymore to be honest with you
i mean i i don't dislike ronnie for
doing that i think it's kind of lame
you're an american you should have a
[ __ ] opinion about something
fred why the [ __ ] do i have to tell
anybody who the [ __ ] i'm voting for
playing it simple why why are you so
afraid to tell everybody now why do i
have to do
why are you so afraid to tell everybody
why do i have to tell anyone
no you don't but it probably would be a
smart idea
why i think what fred is saying ronnie
ronnie i think what fred is saying he's
holding his breath until his balls turn
blue
yeah i think he's saying you always have
been an open book about every other
thing
it's weird that you wouldn't be open
about this everything but this is where
he draws the line
something that's really really important
in this country i mean ronnie told us he
sticks things up his ass but his vote is
too personal so
right i get where fred's coming from ron
i get where he's coming from
well to argue with fred is benji
is now angry with friends oh my god him
i have no
patience for you don't like benji i love
benji but i think he's just
i love benji but this is what goes on
here no no there's a difference there's
a difference
there's a difference between my
relationship and yours you love benji
okay there's nobody no there is a butt
no it is not
hold on hold on ronnie ryan you love
everything let me ask you a question you
love
everything about stephanie you love
stephanie you love every [ __ ] thing
she doesn't say
everything no i don't okay so it's the
same thing we love you but we don't love
everything you do
i have a question for ronnie nobody if
you if he loves nobody
stephanie why aren't they married wait a
minute nobody
wait a minute
married fred you don't know what the
[ __ ] you're talking about with that i
don't
no okay no i don't i did we we are
getting married we just
we're in due time okay
no there's no wedding there'll be no
witnesses
i'll be able to don't worry about it
don't worry what is your point about the
ronnie
relationship let him go back to benji
i'm done
wednesday this wednesday [ __ ]
wednesday i got to [ __ ] go through
the whole [ __ ] weekend and it's
[ __ ]
[ __ ] wednesday what do you mean no
one from work is invited to the wedding
no girl you're the king of ball busting
we all we've all
that's why we love you this is not ball
busting this is [ __ ] true [ __ ] coming
out
what truth did you learn today seriously
end off no i'm serious enough like do
you think fred hates you now
no i didn't say he hated me but i know
how he feels
he's disappointed in your vote but he
still likes you is that he knows
my [ __ ] vote jesus
[ __ ] christ he doesn't think he's
right
he's right i don't know his vote but i
think that you know he really should
take advantage
everybody's so [ __ ] smart here fred
what if i want to know the last time you
[ __ ] your wife
what's that got to do with anything i
i'm curious about it i'd like to
be a man but benji here you are
interrupting with a completely
nonsensical analysis no it's not
i'm talking about what can i can i can i
say honestly
ruins it okay we're done goodbye [ __ ]
fred's head up he doesn't know which
puppet to grab
first you're right there's too many
choices
ronnie i want you to have a good weekend
i don't want you to get all upset
whoa come on come on
oh my goodness fred earned his camera
rights back i might turn this camera